take that [ __ ] strictly to raise your
glasses they're done dude I got these in
another country you idiot Canada can I
try them on
yeah sure yeah yeah are they are they
special do they do stuff huh
no I did [ __ ] up last week are you doing
last week actually worried there's a lot
of mayo I wore those 3d glasses to the
beach actually and they [ __ ] almost
burnt holes in my eyes dude I had him on
in the Sun for about two hours you were
3d glasses out in the Sun it's not good
for you
so Bobby does he he watches for six
hours at a time videos of people with
with who are colorblind hmm and they put
on that those special glasses they're
family oh that's cool tears video the
pass he'll cry I swear I really yeah
like you'll see an old man hmm you put
glasses oh they'll give my pack a happy
birthday grandpa Phillips it's oh why
does he sound like a slave owner we all
chipped in because they're expensive to
get you these whoa the glasses right and
they'll be like yeah the glasses he's
like I gotta try them on right now yeah
yeah right now so he takes them for like
20 minutes to open it yeah and then you
always read the paint like there's
always a UV rays yeah right and then
they put it on and then this is what
generally happened they'll take it off
and look oh my good there's a star
crying for a sec and they'll put it back
on oh good so what happened it's so
beautiful and what is it strippers no
man it is flat if you ever see green
thirty years old bro it doesn't matter
imagine dude imagine your whole life
right yeah you thought that you know the
sky was just gray and then you turn up
or not no yeah magic putting your plug
and then they're blue you see colors for
then they'll go I'll go you see black
and white right now right
well you you'd be he's like wife and
like get it right and here you go here
you go grandpa Phillips right yeah and
then they'll do that yeah and they'll
start crying okay okay okay I don't know
what you're doing right now yeah yeah
and it happens to a lot of senior
citizens [ __ ] [ __ ] address somebody
with a mental illness okay you say this
you [ __ ] idiot you [ __ ] [ __ ] bro
don't make me take a cialis right all
right say this right now okay yeah
colorblind you're born with it yeah are
you their whole life maybe it's mabeline
so their hope you [ __ ] [ __ ] listen
to me right now George laughter alright
do some another country's from Idaho
right so they can see saw was you could
align colorblind there they have it up
their whole lives who just people that
are colour-blind
that's anyone specific yeah I think if
people are colorblind I think we got we
got to get them more colors yeah yeah
you know that's what in chroma does and
here's another series of videos that cry
at yeah here's the hearing one oh yeah
what would they became here fart for the
first time have one some guys never
heard a fart and then he puts on like a
serrated is he go farts huh oh yeah like
20 minutes yeah he's like he's shaking
the guy's butt trying to get him to do
it again and a queef is he oh my
nephew's deaf and he has a cochlear
implant mm-hmm and when he's sick of
everybody
just turns everything off Wow that's an
option that he has he's like I can't oh
and listen to my mom or dad just turns
it off and I think that's gonna be the
future I think you're gonna see a lot
we're gonna start to control our senses
a lot more than then you know like we've
looked at them as blessings in a lot of
ways and I think people were to start to
control them I think it's one thing
you're gonna see people turning down
their ears people being able to shut
their eyes off if they just want to like
stop the intake serious yeah I said well
we really I'm useful for somebody like
me cuz I feel like a lot the stimulus
overwhelms me a lot so if I'm seeing too
many things or if there's too many
things happens we'll just close your
eyes I get freaked out like it causes me
anxiety yeah I have to like receive
things one at a time I can't drown noise
out here at all
why can't you just put earplugs in well
she could Bobby but we're also talking
about technological advancements it
wouldn't be a caveman did you know yeah
but if you don't want to see close your
eyes put earplugs in and then do that or
somebody who is autistic somebody who's
who instead of seeing like for instance
somebody without autism they look at
your face and they just see a face
somebody with autism they look at your
face and they're looking at a million
different photographs like that's how
they perceive things
yes and it's an overwhelming amount of
stimulus that they receive it that they
receive so yeah like if I'm able to turn
that off or mute it it might help 100%
so when they see you they see like a
dream board or something
yeah like when I look at your face it's
just a face right but for them it's like
so many different bits of information
coming all at once yeah it's more than
just a face it's a fiasco it's like
everybody yeah it's like watching like a
it's like watching a marathon or
something's just a lot going on yeah and
I wish I had all you could turn up your
autism like a you know if you had a
crank on your back or some type of a
nozzle you could turn it up to like you
know become more artistic a sparrow yeah
whoa you're really interesting you can
go to Vegas and make a lot of money yeah
you don't wanna be some [ __ ] coop
that uses a like that user for something
positive if you don't be one of those
weirdos in there just cranked up on the
[ __ ] yeah [ __ ] playing [ __ ] combat
game
right around making something no yeah
you're better than that I did that it's
gonna bus up there with seven out of
your buddies just to [ __ ] make $1,200
and come back I'll smoke that on
cigarettes dude maybe a $300 [ __ ]
massage you're better than that
[Music]